it's equifax's data breach the Equifax
breach credit reporting company Equifax
State rating agency Equifax have you
ever heard of a company called Equifax
you might have seen their logo when
applying for a new credit card or taking
out a car loan or mortgage they're one
of the three largest credit bureaus in
the world alongside Experian and
Transunion and they're in charge of
determining your credit worthiness given
their role in the market I don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that Equifax
deals with a significant amount of
sensitive data like name age date of
birth address phone number annual income
and social security number this has made
Equifax a prime target for hackers and
cyber terrorists looking to commit
identity theft and credit card fraud now
I'm sure that Equifax tries their best
to protect this information and given
that their company's reputation is on
the line but unfortunately their efforts
weren't quite enough in September of
2017 Equifax announced a ground breaking
data breach that affected a
mind-boggling
147 million people and given the nature
of their business the data being leaked
wasn't your cat pictures or YouTube
subscriptions it was your financial
profile it was the names of 147 million
people the date of births of 147 million
people the social security numbers of
146 million people and so much more this
data breach was so large that if you're
an American and watching this video it's
more likely that you were affected than
it is that you weren't affected here's
the thing the US population stands at
330 million people out of which 22.3
percent or under 18. this means that
only 256 million Americans were even
capable of having data saved with
Equifax and yes I know that teenagers
under 18 can have a credit file but
that's extremely rare so out of this 256
million Americans 146 million had their
assassins leaked in other words if
you're an American adult in 2017 and had
any sort of credit history there's over
a 55 chance that your SSN was leaked
through this data breach and even if
yours wasn't leaked it's highly likely
that you know someone whose was and
that's just in America this data breach
also affected 15.2 million people in the
UK and a 19 000 Canadians but how did
such a catastrophic data breach even
materialize and what can you do if you
were affected
taking a look back the story of the data
breach dates back to December of 2016
months before the breach actually took
place at the time a security researcher
looked into the servers and websites of
Equifax and he noticed something strange
it appeared that everyday people had
access to some sort of employee side and
you didn't even need credentials to
access it one of the portals on the site
had search fields and you could search
through the personal data of Equifax
customers all you had to do was put in a
search term and get millions of results
just instantly and that was just the
beginning of it the researcher also
founded that it was extraordinarily easy
to get shell access to several Equifax
servers additionally they also uncovered
multiple vulnerabilities such as SQL
injection while these were all major
security risks on the bright side they
were also very easy to patch Equifax
could have taken down the employee
portals in minutes and they could have
packed the server flaws within a week
and at Equifax even had the opportunity
to do exactly this given that the
researcher reached out to them but as
you were to guess Equifax didn't do that
at least not quick enough according to
the researcher this security researcher
wasn't the only one that was tipping up
Equifax either a few months later in
March of 2017 the U.S Department of
Homeland Security would reach out to
Equifax regarding a need to patch some
of their software given that this notice
was literally coming from the US
government and a non-stem security
researcher Equifax would immediately
take action just one day following the
notice Equifax would notify their cyber
security Personnel about the need to
upgrade their Apache stretch software
within just 48 hours they would
apparently patch the bugs and about a
week later the security department would
even run scans to verify that the bugs
were patched and the scans apparently
revealed no vulnerabilities but for some
reason none of these efforts actually
patched the bugs to be honest it appears
to me that Equifax cared more about
putting down on paper that they
responded quickly to the government
notice and the character bot actually
fixing the bug but that's just my own
speculation anyway regardless of why the
bug wasn't patched the bottom line is
that it wasn't patched and did this
opened up the perfect opportunity for
hackers to strike about two months later
on May 13 2017 attackers would begin
accessing sensitive personal data using
this bug and it wasn't just a one-time
thing either they would consistently
access sensitive data for the next two
and a half months it wasn't until July
29th that Equifax Security Department
would have finally notice suspicious
Network traffic Equifax would of course
patch the bug for real this time almost
instantaneously but the damage had
already been done cool
initially Equifax had no idea about the
magnitude or depth of the data breach in
the words of the CEO himself I certainly
did not know that personal identifying
information had been stolen or have any
indication of the scope of this attack
nonetheless Equifax would go ahead and
get their lawyers on board and follow
their data breach protocol one of the
first steps in this protocol was to
complete a thorough forensic
investigation and let's just say that it
didn't take long for this investigation
to reveal some terrible news by August
11th it was cleared to Equifax that this
wasn't just some small leak it appeared
that hackers had accessed entire
databases and the data being stolen was
spread across a multitude of data tables
which made it especially hard linked to
Stone data with individual customers
this is one of the main reasons that it
took Equifax so long to publicly
announce the data breach but eventually
by September 4th the investigative team
would have put together a comprehensive
list of 143 million victims and on
September 7 2017 Equifax would publicly
announce exactly what happened
as you would have guessed the reaction
was not pretty Equifax stock would
crater nearly 40 percent within a matter
of days and the public would have become
more aware of the company than ever
before interest in Equifax literally
exploded 20x in the days following the
public announcement but almost as
quickly as the drama unfolded it the
drama wrapped up by the end of 2017
interest in Equifax returned to their
normal non-existent levels stock took
longer to recover but that too would
return to all-time highs within two
years in fact since then Equifax stock
has grown as much as 102 percent somehow
Equifax has been able to live this town
with extremely low levels of backlash
from the general public and I think the
main reason for this is that the average
person did not have strong opinions
about Equifax going into the drama
imagine it if this same thing happened
with Facebook who people already
associated with the data intrusion we'd
literally have riots on social media
even though the data leaked by Facebook
would probably be less sensitive this
isn't to say that Equifax didn't receive
any backlash at all however the backlash
that they did receive was rather
short-lived and the people forgot about
it pretty quickly and a given that the
public wasn't really holding Equifax
accountable it was up the Equifax
themselves and Regulators to take action
much of equifax's leadership would
either leave voluntarily or be forced
out equifax's Chief Information officer
Chief security officer and CEO would all
retire within a few weeks after the
Public Announcement it appears that
these guys prefer to take the easy way
out in terms of the FDC it would
eventually settle with Equifax for a 575
million dollars to 700 million dollars
depending on how many people actually
claimed images while this is definitely
a hefty fine for government standards
it's not too bad from an equifax's
perspective after all Equifax makes more
than that on an annual basis so they
were only set to back one year even
though they leaked the data of literally
half of American adults clearly Equifax
was able to get away with a small slap
on the wrist but the same it could not
be said about the victims
ironically one of the first problems
that victims faced was due to Equifax
once again you see it shortly after the
breach became public Equifax created a
website where people could claim losses
it was definitely the right thing to do
but unfortunately Equifax didn't do it
correctly instead of creating a portal
under their official domain at
equifax.com Equifax decided that it
would be a great idea to create a new
domain just for claims called Equifax
security2017it.com to this day I have no
idea why they decide to do this maybe it
was the distance the claims from their
main website I'm not sure but what I am
sure about is that this new domain was a
terrible Choice first of all it made it
hard for people to tell whether they
were on the official website and this
led to the rise of several scam websites
with similar domains even equifax's own
support team was confused and at one
point they were directing consumers to
one of these fake websites themselves
this is clearly not a great look but on
the bright side correctly claiming
damages with Equifax could result in a
payout as high as twenty thousand
dollars the initial claim window closed
up at the beginning of 2020 but an
extended claim window is still open
until January of 2024. the average
victim will obviously not to be paid
anywhere near twenty thousand dollars
but if you had any sort of credit file
in 2017 or before it is worth checking
out you may be able to get a few hundred
dollars from them this compensation is
of course not worth having your data
compromised but there's also no reason
to forego claiming this compensation
also you'll probably get a much better
idea as to how much data was stolen from
you if any aside from offering claims
Equifax also rolled out a couple of
Goodwill programs shortly after the
Fiasco for example they offered victims
free credit monitoring services for four
years now you might be saying why would
anyone want to give Equifax any more
data given their history and that is a
fair point but you can look at it from a
different perspective as well given what
happened to Equifax it's likely that
there are more keen on cyber security
than ever before they've apparently
invested 1.5 billion dollars into
technology and security since 2018. so
you would hope that things are different
but then again Experian and Transunion
probably also buffed up their security
after this incident so it may be better
to just stick with them instead
foreign
if we learned anything from this
incident it's that the biggest threat to
our privacy may not be as
straightforward as a Google or Facebook
background Financial companies like
credit bureaus lenders and Underwriters
have more sensitive data about all of us
than big Tech does yet they receive a
virtually no criticism because we don't
interact with them on a regular basis
and them collecting this data is seen as
an essential part of their business but
the only way that we can get these
institutions to take on more
accountability is by shining the
spotlight on them just like we've been
doing with big Tech Apple's ask not to
track future was a game changer and the
main reason that came to fruition is
thanks to all the attention surrounding
big Tech data collection if there was
more tensions running the creative space
consumers may get more Choice there as
well for example when we apply for a
credit card with Amex we might be able
to choose which credit bureau they used
to run our credit by implementing such
features we may be able to prevent
future instances of complacency from
occurring but that's just what I think
did you know about this massive data
leak from Equifax comment that down
below also drop a like if you think
these companies need to be held more
accountable and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community
suggest for the video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered until then I'm Hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one
thank you